it is life hacks this is kind of like
the second season i really hope there's
somebody listening to this episode who's
not got any of the weird references
so far i just think we've all got
tourette's have you seen the alan
partridge thing where he's talking about
how to wash your hands and train toilet
without touching anything so he's like
elbow elbow soap soap tissue tissue down
kick the door open
done that's how my morning feels
yusef why have you put kermit the frog
behind you on you
he's he's back again can you can you
just
tell me when he goes i cannot i cannot
believe
it is life hacks time with johnny and
youssef from propanefitness.com how are
you doing gentlemen good
all very good good are you doing the
macarena
i don't think it's like that is it it's
that that looked more like a mime artist
pretending there was a glass wall
pretending to do the macarena
i'm i'm not very up to date with my like
90s dance
90s dance moves yeah if younger boys
yeah if it was anything after wenger
boys or craig david's debut single
that's
that's your most current music isn't it
it's like how you surprised like one
series in one film to talk about when
someone's like
within each decade yeah yeah i've i've
seen breaking bad
all of breaking bad and i've seen fight
club i think you may need to reverse
maintain semblance is it like fight club
is it like fight club so look i i
actually know pop culture very well
um it is life hacks we only done
one new life hacks episode proper lifx
episode in 2020
so we should have tons and i've got
loads i know you guys have got loads as
well
also before we started i wanted to say
thank you to everyone that's downloaded
the ultimate life hacks guide if you
haven't got yours
chris will x dot com slash life hacks
over 200 ways that you can upgrade your
life
and it covers everything we've done up
to now so this is kind of like
the second season second season of life
hacks
lifehacks a new beginning a new frontier
uh so hot potato johnny you are up what
have you got for us first
so mine are split between physical and
digital
the ogs will know yeah if you get that
joke
congratulations congratulations which
one to pick
that's the thing that's the question
here's a really basic it's not
anything i've got none yeah
uh what's something i've been doing
recently so i re-read
atomic habits we all like atomic habits
don't we just not read it yet
i'm reading two books currently traffic
secrets and atomic habits
what a set what a setup so i
basically have i mean this is a
not not that relevant but i've started
eating breakfast
so while things are cooking in the pan
in the morning
i basically do all of the like
chores in the kitchen so i like take the
bin out empty the dishwasher wipe the
surfaces
and then i can't forget it's happened
and you go back in the kitchen you're
like ah
this is clean this is tidy so it's just
because although like previously the
first couple of times i was doing was
just like standing looking at the pan
like waiting for it to warm up so just
using dead time like that
and there was another example um
a good example of that from an old one
is when you were
flossing your teeth in the shower yusef
yeah exactly exactly so that sort of
thing
i mean um you know when it's a really
good life hack when separately we
haven't talked about it but yeah i do
the same thing as you
yeah i have on a morning my housemate
makes fun of me because we've been
getting up at
similar sort of times during lockdown
and there's this weird ballet
that i do around the kitchen when i'm
making my food because i'm prepping my
whole food
for the whole day and i'm also washing
up and i'll wash all of his stuff
because i don't mind
and i've got my podcast on but i'm like
going like
cooker sink pirouette microwave freezer
yeah it's like this elaborate dance
thing
where are you going like 50s like mary
poppins music playing in the background
it's ben shapiro's podcast usually which
actually makes you move a lot quicker
what was the other what was the other
example have you seen the alan partridge
thing where he's talking about how to
wash your hands and train toilet without
touching anything
no so he's like elbow elbow soap soap
tissue tissue down kick the door open
done that's how my morning feels well i
mean
it's so much better like why wouldn't
you use the time when you're cooking
your food to do other things what you
can do just look at your food cooking
there's a huge number how do people do
that oh it
wasted time there's so much opportunity
for that where like we so we discussed
uh this with a process engineer on one
of our podcasts called
efficiency is everything recently and he
talks very much about like there's just
hundreds of opportunities during the day
where you set a process in motion
that requires time but no further input
until it's done
such as breakfast in the pan and then
you just go
do all the stuff in between set another
process in motion and it's like it's all
about
finding what are those initial trigger
processes that you can just
set going and so he talks about i think
we we discussed this on
probably one of the last ones about when
henry ford
gave his presentation of turning on
putting on a suit
or washing your is it washing your balls
first in the shower washing your head
first in the shower
you wash your hair first and it drips
down yeah the henry ford example is
great so he was talking about how he
puts on a
suit and he does his shirt from the
bottom up
and then ties his tie because his hands
are moving bottom up to the neck
does the tie puts that round does the
thing you know so
yeah i like that have you got any other
do you see had another example of what
you do
so it's just so like in in that process
i will
like take the bin out what like empty
the dishwasher reload the dishwasher
with anything that needs to be put in
fill up three of these and put them in
the fridge
so then i just hap because like a big
resistant i don't really like drinking
water and that sounds ridiculous but
like
left to my own devices i just won't
drink water but if there's like chilled
bottles in the fridge ready to go
much so much easier so like often i'll
go back to the kitchen at like 11 a.m
forget that i've done all of this i
might yes kitchens the kitchens are
coming
clean in here i've got chilled water and
everything like this
this is brilliant becca someone the
cleaning fairies have been again
man it's so much so much of the stuff
that you can do can be like
future johnny will thank past johnny
that he hasn't even remembered i
remember one of my housemates his
girlfriend used to drunk clean
so she'd come in from a night out and
clean the whole house drunk
because she said the next day it was
like she hadn't done it
that's clever that's really good yeah i
really like that
my my flatmate did that when she first
tried jack 3d
remember that pre-workout that got
banned um
she she was someone who was no stranger
to class a drugs as well
and i was i had some and she was like
what's that can i try some
and i was like yeah fine i went to the
gym came back and the house was spotless
and she was like i've had a really good
day so i've been really productive i've
cleaned the whole house
i'm like okay have you got any idea why
that might be the case
no i just feel like he's full of energy
i don't know what's going on brilliant
all the time for some reason
a little bit sweaty a little bit clammy
but yeah yeah jaws jaws going
okay so do your chores whilst cooking
breakfast and make use of dead time
yousef what you got so mine
is coffee bags i have discovered this
recently
by uh johnny's really upset this is
probably a very like
absolute philistine thing to say for
coffee aficionados like you've got some
coffee you just put it in the cup you
pop through it
it's really quick um no so it it's the
same niceness as
proper coffee because it is just in a
like a bag that's more
permeable than a tea bag only discovered
this by accident because
a girlfriend went to buy some coffee
knew that
i didn't have all the right coffee kit
so she bought some coffee bags
turned up and realized that they were
decaf got really upset
and was like you just keep them i'm not
touching those horrible things
brilliant so now i've got a box of
coffee bags in the house
is that what you were drinking in your
big cup this was actually a
mushroom cocoa i think on your
recommendation johnny
second hand i got it because of hearing
you talk about it on previous life hacks
and now i had some as a filtered stuff
like that makes me feel uneasy because
it's like
mike without me knowing has listened to
something i said a while ago
has gone out and done something and now
you've got it in a mug
it's a relaxant though you are aware of
that it's like
one one is the chaga and one is
cordyceps so this morning i was training
my cordyceps and then i had some of the
mushrooms then you had a chaga
all right what's your what's
i could see in your facial expression
that you had a criticism about coffee
bags johnny what's your
so so one of mine is um
becca bought me a temperature kettle now
you might think
surely all kettles do temperature how is
this different
um it's a it's a kettle that you set the
temperature and it it boils up to a
certain it's got a
special spout on it that allows you to
pour water into a filter
funnel where i've been using the 466
method
to brew coffee so it's quite very manual
very slow
but delicious so just contrast that too
so that was one of my life hacks
contrast that to yusuf's coffee bags
don't keep on you've got the full
spectrum
wow what's what is the 466 method you
might as well go again
um it's so you you i mean
i'll probably get some of this wrong but
it's i think japanese coffee prep method
where you weigh out 20 grams of beans
grind them
put them into a filter paper um beans
and then you pour an initial amount of
water on it
then you wait for the bloom which is the
the carbon dioxide being released from
the beans
and then you wait and then you pour more
water weight
pour more water in a four six six
pattern so rather than be going through
like the full
crap so it's it's very it's it's like a
um a real craft process to make a coffee
isn't it amazing the the branding of
japan like
if you say anything's oh it uses a
japanese method everyone's like
must be so like systematically it's like
this this isn't just any bread roll and
butter this is icelandic bread
and an [ __ ] it's nice of course it's
900
discounted down to 9 000 pounds
so chris what's yours coffee bags have
you got a brand for those
scope no i think just any biodegradable
one the only thing i would avoid
is that this is
tinfoil hat but you know the really
fancy tea that so it's in like a sort of
silken
mesh tea pigs have that kind of it's
like a pyramid style or a
i don't know what you're talking about
but okay what's the like
try something he drawn that's like a
pyramid with a triangle base
okay um it's like that silky mesh
not a normal tea bag not biodegradable
they
are the worst thing for plastic and
estrogen exposure
because they send off little micro
particles of estrogen which is like
oh i've got some of my cupboards i've
got tea pigs in my cupboards they are
they're absolutely terrible so you don't
want anyone that's using tea pigs just
throw them in the bin
oh pin them immediately yeah or give
them to someone that you want to have
more easily in fact
ironically one of the the best ways to
clear out estrogen
is because your liver cannot process it
can't um
filter out the the artificial estrogens
is to sweat them out
so sweat has a high proportion of
artificial estrogens that you can
excrete
best way to do that sauna no saunas
available all year
probably won't be for another six to ten
months that makes me sad man
it's like the coronavirus hub isn't it
making you making you full of estrogen
okay so coffee bags 466 method for
coffee
uh my first one which we haven't covered
airpod pros
so they've been out for a little while
we've covered these like every episode
no i don't we have nope
i think we have just written i i've just
written
an entire life look airpods was on the
first ever episode airpod pros so
i got them the day they came out i drove
to the metro center to get them on the
evening that they came
out i got my buddy who works there to
reserve a pair for me which was good
and then four months later johnny
and jordan from modern museum big dick's
group got a hold of a pair
and started extolling the virtues and
telling me about just how great they
were
chris have you seen these chris you
should get some of these
they're just if anyone that's listening
if you've got 240 pounds to spend on a
pair of headphones if you use them a lot
you you literally can't get better
they're the same price as any other pair
of noise cancelling headphones the noise
canceling in them you might think oh why
do i need some noise canceling it that
doesn't sound very interesting
it it is just you existing inside of
your own mind
as opposed to you being within the world
it's so good you can afford to have the
sound turned down a much lower level
because the ambient noise coming in is
competing with it much less which means
if you had problems with old airpods
or wired headphones in a loud place like
the gym or when you're driving or
something else
it's just it's a wonderful experience
battery life is still very strong
i've had mine for probably eight months
now i guess since they came out
and i don't regret buying them at all
one thing i would say is
buy the apple care plus which extends
the warranty for a couple of years
and i think is maybe 30 pounds so all in
you're looking at about 270 pounds but
they're they're just amazing if you
listen you're listening to this podcast
presumably you consume a lot of audio
content
the old airpods are perfectly acceptable
but if you've got the extra 100 pounds
to spend it is worth it that's
so actually one one thing to add on that
as well is um
if you've got 10 pounds to spare and
you're not a [ __ ] then um
you can uh you can get these which are
the anker
10-pound bluetooth headphones you can
actually get 30
pairs of these before you have to buy
one set of airpods
if you're not a [ __ ] yeah yeah i think
what you meant to say was
if you look if you want to import your
headphones via yemen
yeah you can i was in i was in topshop
with becca in elton square and i walked
past this is when i still had out you
know
back in like 1999 when i had my normal
airpods
and uh i was i walked past and i saw
like the
box on the window and i was like god
they look really nice and i'm like
walking around top shop like this is
boring i was like
i wonder whether there's any reviews
like you know non-biased reviews about
airpod pros you google it and it's just
like
page after page of these are the best
headphones ever produced
so i was like i'll just be back in a
moment
it's the sign of a great product when
you see the advert and then you're like
oh
i'm like in a bit there's a visceral
reaction because i don't own them yeah
it's apple do this thing to me where i
imagine you both probably have the same
thing where
they release something and you think
that looks pretty expensive
but you kind of know that at some point
you're going to buy them it's just a
matter of time it's like this
horizon i'm not stupid like a pencil and
you're like
yeah and then
before you know it it's before you know
it's in your house yeah exactly
wow so yeah when i was drunk airport
airport pros final
lovely thing about airpod pros if you're
on a plane the best way
to notice the difference in noise
cancelling is if you're on a plane so
you can imagine that usually it's
really actually quite loud and you don't
realize how loud it is until you can't
hear it anymore
and it's not the same as not having
noise because you need the noise
cancelling
so if you just put ear plugs in that's
not the same as noise cancelling
so you go from like
[Music]
and it's it's so good i was next to a
crying child which is obviously like
on a long flight everyone's worst
nightmare on the way out to bali an
extra crying child i just looked at it
and i was like
you just squeeze it don't you give him a
squeeze give me
what you want transparency mode of like
so if i'm like while i'm doing my
kitchen routine with my elbows and
everything
becca speaks to me i'm just like he goes
and then suddenly it's like the music
being played from over there yeah
and it's ambient noise i need to um
i need to kind of caveat that you will
look like an ignorant [ __ ]
a lot with them in because the number of
times my housemate said something to me
behind me
if it's on noise cancelling with sound
playing in it
you're not getting you're not getting
anything there can be a fire
and you're not gonna you're not gonna
know about the fire yeah so can you put
noise cancelling
without anything playing yes yeah so you
can just
and is there a setting for that you just
say enable you just turn turn noise
cancelling on and don't play music
yeah just put them in if you put them in
and press and hold them they'll just so
i
i can't see a use case for them if if if
like you're someone that flies a lot
or you you're someone someone that has a
noisy job or whatever like i would love
that in the office because there's a lot
of like yeah
but that with a binaural beats or you
know just something
low playing in the background is very
very silent
it's phenomenal it's just not very ppe
like wearing a surgical mask and with
episodes of ipods i think if a doctor
came up to me and
i had airpods and i'd be like come on
mate you're like this is the worst day
of my life could you like at least you
could do
one airpod not have your airpods you
also need to be able to hear like
arrest alarms and phone calls and that
kind of thing so if that could link in
those somehow with your airpods
better than a better than a pager isn't
it definitely
two things on them something that ben
mentioned to me was like you know
the vision of the future of where you're
just plugged into the internet
having airpods in that have anytime
siri like pickup is that is pretty close
to that if you think about it
because all you have you just have to
say the right words and you can
sense when a message happens yeah call
someone search something on google
put something in your to-do list
schedule something in your calendar like
it's
so i do it often while i'm like mid-set
not mid-set
between right the technology already
exists for that like i watched a video
of this coder who just decided for fun
to do that you know we can request
a download of all your data from
facebook or google or whatever he did it
with google
and it sent him 175 gigabytes
of data that he could download and it
was just hosted on a public url like
obviously a long string of characters
and stuff and it was like
long audio recordings of just like
pre like before him saying like okay
google or whatever
and he went through some of them and one
of them was like google do you ever have
um problems when your diarrhea is so bad
that you and he's like well okay
like but it's it's insane how much
he's like if they've only got that much
data on me like imagine multiply that by
everyone else uh okay so johnny what you
got
um lasting on airpods
so i found this thing called um you
might have heard of it chris i don't
think you have come across this called
better touch tool
i don't know whether you've heard of it
before um so basically if i press
command shift a
it connects my laptop to my ipods from
my phone to my airpods
johnny i'm so proud that's a good switch
over an easy way to switch over you
yeah yeah i have challenges making it
work with my macbook
i tend not to every guest that i've
podcasted with
who's tried to use airpods or ipod pros
to do a
podcast has challenges whether it's on
skype whether it's on zoom whether it's
on
like whatever they just tend to have
challenges it seems to be a little bit
better optimized for your phone than it
is for your laptop
i think they're great for for facetime
more like
audio calls but less so for zoom or
something like that yeah
okay have i mentioned brain fm before
i don't think i have yes but we can go
we can go through it just because i
don't think he went in very deep
so it's it's something that so i've
tried lots of these services in the past
i've tried like
focus at will um there's another one i
can't remember the name of it like they
play by number beats they play like
noise
to try and help you focus um brain fm is
one i've tried more recently and it
i i mean i think youssef's tried it and
doesn't notice anything there's a few
other people i've mentioned it too who
have seen a huge
boost in in like focus and concentration
so br they do like a three-day free
trial i think so brain fm
they have like a focus playlist a
relaxation playlist
a nap playlist a meditation playlist for
different
types of um binaural beats basically
it's quite a lot of research behind what
they're doing like they produce a white
paper behind all of the
the the research they're doing and they
sponsor like
it's well it's free for three days and
then it's like
10 pounds a month or 5.99 a month or
something in that range it's very
expensive then for buying
it it is it is so you have to so that's
why i think like
get the trial see if you notice anything
but ben's even said things like
he noticed he started procrastinating
and then realized that the
procrastination had started
at the end of his like 30 minute focus
music window and stuff like that so
i think try some people like it some
people don't i get a lot out of it
but try it for yourself they also have a
it's a web there's a web version as well
which i really like
it is quite nice from a musical quality
perspective as well like it's
unintrusive and i think the music is
designed not to be like
surprising it's all just very like
and i i think like i i'm not up to date
with the data on binaural beats last
time i checked
it was very inconclusive but that was
like a few years ago so
as with most of this stuff though if you
believe in it sufficiently that like the
placebo effect is the most reliable
effect in all the pharmacology isn't it
if you could bottle the placebo effect
you'd have a panacea um so ben
greenfield
ben greenfield loves brain fm he says
that this is part of his daily part of
his daily routine when he has his nap
i don't think he says he didn't mention
that he uses it as part of work
but he uses it for his naps so if it's
good enough for ben it might be good
enough for everyone else i like is a
referral code have you got a referral
code or anything like that i probably do
yeah just give me the link it'll be in
the show notes below everything that we
talk about airpod pros
uh whatever coffee bags i managed to
find and all that stuff are always
linked in the show notes all
in the description on youtube yusuf what
you got
so as you know mine are split into
different categories
um this one is a social one chris
it was you um it's to ask a friend to
take you
clothes shopping i think you get a layer
of objectivity
no matter how good or bad your sense of
style is like mine was
terrible but the t-shirt i'm wearing
right now in fact the shorts i'm wearing
now as well
plus everything you're seeing here beard
nose ring tattoo
it's all just chris and a friend of mine
called david who i think are both
equally attractive men but on different
ends of the the male style spectrum
and they both had a concordance with
what they were recommending that i do
image-wise and fashion-wise and and
it started with burn those horrible
green loafers and every purple cardigan
that you've got
get rid of your tracksuit bottoms and
just let me bloody take you shopping
and chris kindly took me to the metro
center and
just went through top to toe sorted me
out
and that's lasted for years now i've
just been re-wardrobed thanks to chris
yeah i think that's a really good way to
do it like asking your friend to do
anything that's kind of
like if what do you think about this is
a haircut what do you think about this
as a
as a potential style chain or whatever
you know like getting that third-party
perspective is good
but especially with clothes shopping i
don't have massive amounts of style and
i appreciate the fact that you've like
put me across as some sort of style guru
here like [ __ ] gokuan
but um uh
you are right like just having someone
there who can go
um maybe maybe not that maroon cardigan
mate not maybe not maybe not another one
um well that's it as long as your friend
you know that your friend has your best
interests at heart and they're not just
trolling you
i think johnny felt as though we were
trolling him with by trying to get him
to
a top notch but as much as we try and
convince him we were 100
dead serious that he would look like a
samurai
samurai i just whether looking like a
samurai is is the desire it's like an
outcome you would like
or i'm sure i would have looked like a
samurai it's just is that a good thing
or not i'm sure if you're trying to be a
samurai it's the best thing
i told dave rubin that he should get a
top knot because we tried to get you to
get a top knot and he didn't do it
either
so next up next up from me
the new reebok nano x's so
i've used reebok's crossfit training
shoes since the eights came out
the eights were phenomenal the nines
were phenomenal and the x's are even
better
like they're just ridiculously
comfortable they look better than most
fashion trainers do
they've finally managed to nail the
colourways in them so if you're
in the gym regularly if you're training
especially if you're doing anything
plyometric any squats anything that
requires you to drive force through your
feet
you need a stable pair of shoes now you
can get away with a pair of low
vans or converse they're okay but
the number of times that i see people in
like
classic nike running shoes you know like
just like a
soft floppy pair of nike running shoes
that you can
fold in half like this which are
comfortable for wearing around day to
day
but when you watch someone squat in
those shoes
you see that outside the edge
of their feet starting to peel the
in the inner um arch of their feet off
the ground
and you're like me there's not many
degrees of freedom left between you and
just snapping your [ __ ]
like you have to be able to have a shoe
which is stable and is able to it allows
you to push into the ground
um the nano x's they're absolutely
amazing i can't
if you go to the gym stop wearing nike
rushes
like they're not even shoes let alone
training shoes
stop wearing vapor max which are those
things with the little bubbles on the
bottom of them
they're also why would you wear those
like why would you choose to lift in
these things it's always
it seems to me to always be the guys
that consider themselves really serious
gym goers
they're the ones that have got like a
three-piece fully coordinated nike
outfit
with the headband on and the sweatband
and
i like right okay you obviously have
taken a lot of time to think about this
what's happening what's happening with
the shoes like there's no
anyway nike nano x ed reebok nanowx's
you need a pair
it's a it's better than the person who
wears like um
construction boots and a tank top and
straps to come in and do like heavy
shrugs and leave
that's a very good castle thing to do
that's a very newcastle thing to do
how many times you say if in gold star
gym have you had to brush
plaster dust off the bench before you've
been able to get down on oh i'm
i'm out of place for wearing gym clothes
like
because i'm not in hi-vis and
[Laughter]
i mean that i i kind of respect the guys
because obviously like you've come
straight from graft
you haven't even had the time to get
changed out of the clothes you wore at
work
so presumably your day must be so
strapped down to the second that you
couldn't even go into the changing room
to decide to get out of the paint and
plaster covered
rig as rigor boots and stuff that you
wore during the day
or or maybe that's a performance
enhancer
that none of us have ever seen and
rigger boots are actually the best squat
shoes that you can find these guys are
operating on
really high level they're either like
bastions of like efficiency
or it's uh yeah it's just atomic habits
that's all it's all about environment
design but there are definitely some
people who
put those those boots on for the
purposes of training
you kidding absolutely there's i've seen
some
there's some in the gym that we've all
been to a few people
oh wow wow i mean this is we're getting
into brian rose conspiracy theory
territory here aren't we okay what you
got so we got next johnny
link to that so i wasn't going to say
this but linked to training shoes
i have just changed so for the first
time in
i think probably can't remember
it's a long time i've just bought some
new squat shoes so they're no longer
bright yellow
and they are the romalio fours you had
the twos
i had the twos correct no one i know
knows what the romalio ones looked like
looked like
nope they must have existed but there's
romalio twos
mario threes and the romalio fours and
they are incredible
absolutely incredible so the romalio
threes
the size because they were quite light
so the romalio twos are like a brick
like you put your foot in a brick and
then
you're stationary on the ground and that
your feet don't slide around at all
malleo3s are made a bit lighter because
they're a weightlifting shoe
and then the romalio4s are just very
very stable they've got like straps and
laces and they're just cool
they're just really good yeah
a good pair of squat shoes especially if
you squat
like if you're doing a lot of squatting
the way a pair of like
weightlifting shoes make you feel when
you train incredible yeah so i mean
for people that might not know the
difference between something like the
nanox and the rom 4s is that you will
have a much higher
heel on the lifting shoes that permits
you to get more range through your hips
more dorsiflexion there you go exactly
though
those black ones they look badass man
yeah but yeah i think
the vast majority of people if you don't
know what a pair of lifting shoes are
you probably don't need a pair of
lifting shoes
but yeah if you don't know what a pair
of nano x's are
you still might need a pair of them
because like
ignorance to get you through the door
you could be wearing something which is
potentially going to snap your [ __ ]
whereas if you don't know what lifting
shoes are you're probably not squatting
to a sufficiently high
volume the metric we use is if you if
you're squatting 1.5 body weight
you've unlocked the right to get some
shoes
when you're squatting twice body weight
you can get a belt oh right
i love that i love that as a as a little
it's because and you guys have to be you
know much more
face to face with this daily in the
crossfit gym
which is there are many people who have
all the gear
yet no idea and they have not
unlocked that achievement but they've
tried to get the cheat codes
doesn't work power lifters like the
amount of kit that they come in with
and the thing is that for a lot of them
a lot of you guys it's
perfectly justified heavy ass weight
like
a lot of heavy ass weight but
when you can measure the amount of kit
you've got in
square meters on the floor that someone
comes they open their bag up
and it's just like a stuff starts flying
out
and when you include like bags of haribo
and like
multiple cans of white monster in that
because you've got to carb up for those
three reps that you're doing like
the the thing that um johnny and i were
discussing the other day
was a guy back from the like the old
school golden era
of fitness called pete rubish
who is just this freak deadlifter who
would train in his like
in this basement and he's just got this
like washing machine like rattling in
the background and he's just in
shorts with plates that have been
sellotaped together
and he's just a nutter he's just this
completely like unhinged headlifter he's
pulling
ridiculous amounts of weight just in
shorts and barefoot
for years and years and it's like that
is the man who deserves
to get himself a better allowance
while we're on this i want to ask what
do you deadlift in and what do you
mention
uh okay so i
what what well that was just a really
like bad grammar question
what do you deadlift in and what do you
mention
bro listen yeah i want to know
what is you dead lifting in what is your
deadlift
so my um i dead lift actually at the
moment
completely barefoot wow
okay controversial scene completely
naked
yeah just to be honest this is so like
one
like in training in my garage like i
the other day i was like i'll just not
bother putting my deadlift shoes on see
how it feels it feels mint
like being completely barefoot dead
lifting feels absolutely class
so that do you mean in terms of shoes
yeah yeah
so and then benches flat shoes some
people
i think that's because of my morphology
um like the way i have to put my feet to
get like
legal form a lot of people deadlift
bench sorry in
in lifting shoes as well to get like
extra clearance off the ground you can
get your feet closer to you
and still have heels on the ground if
you are 85.5 percent legs
that's not yeah that's then obviously
yeah you actually want less
if anything the thing that's that's very
unfair is that in
competition people with short legs are
allowed a block to put their feet on
right because they can't reach the
ground oh okay didn't
right but like for me i you know i have
the opposite problem
why can i not have holes in the ground
like as soon as as soon as we're moving
the bar here of like what you can and
can't have like
a really good point it was tim garrett
who told me about it because otherwise
that assumes that um the bench is
maximum height and anything
putting blocks up is for accommodate for
shorter people
which is not true this is the how wide
should airplane seats be
discussion all over again oh yeah we
don't need to get into that
okay so um barefoot for deadlifting and
flat shoes or
lifters depending on your height for
benching uh yusef what you got next
this is an app called get human
i don't think we've discussed this in
the previous ones this is where
you will save hundreds of hours where if
you're on the phone to like customer
service or whatever trying to
like upgrade a service for something or
tech support
and you put on hold listening to the
same 10 seconds of craig david
that's where you can use get human and
it
holds the call for you and calls you
back when a human answers the phone
it's not 100 reliable because it
involves
the per the operator like pressing a
button as well and then it calls you
back
but rather than having to sit on the
phone and wait on hold
it's pretty good that's i mean so i
don't actually mind the
the concept behind it i have to say that
if i is it free yep
why why are they doing this i don't
understand what's up it's because
there are many i think they run on
advertising there are many companies
that have an automatic callback service
but i think and i i'm convinced of this
that
a lot of companies customer service and
tech support particularly during covid
is deliberately obstructive and
deliberately
difficult to act as a deterrent so you
don't call them up the same way that if
you try and like speak to a
customer service rep for like one of the
budget airline companies
you get the dark patterns on the back
end of the customer support thing
do you want to submit do you want to
check out our like forum
where other people have submitted
answers to your question well i don't
want to go and search for other people
asking the same question that i've asked
and not getting a response
i just want a man this is why man
this is why i love bulb bulb energy
that's it that's why
you can it's amazing you just call them
up and they're like hello bulb and
you're like
well i wasn't ready for that um
well i've got a problem if you call
apple so apple initially it's like
there's a there's a bot that says i am a
automated bot i can handle any plain
text
sentence just say what you need and
you're like okay
say a sentence and then a couple of
seconds later it's like
i'm mate through to apple and it's
clearly just i'm a guy at home
like it just it was like i've got this
question all right all right no
problem yeah how can i help out what the
[ __ ]
is this international company trillions
of things happening right and yeah
they've just got a bloke who probably
lives on my road
to help me out i had a i had an irish
girl pop up with the assistance that i
needed for garageband it's like i
couldn't work out how to turn off midi
metronome
summing something and did exactly that i
can't remember there being
me just saying a thing i think i might
have submitted it online and then they
rang me
uh if you ring them bring them in the
initially there's a that's an
ai that's intense i don't spend that
long waiting though
for me neither me neither do you think
it's it's it's part of the
architecture isn't it
ecology the ecology of a scoby problem
has been built into the structure of the
space time
it has these long weights because
it's not me it's not me that submitted
the initial request it was actually my
sister
and my sister decided that she was going
to do it with a credit card which then
she cancelled actually there's an
ongoing lawsuit to do with that so we're
going to have to get
it it results in you having to go to
your local news agents to get
a card to plug in to like to put more
energy into your house
so luckily the most recent one was me
this is another life hack was
me upgrading my internet speed so going
from virgin
like 100 megabit to just the maximum
thing
and it like because of covert everyone's
decided that nothing can run anymore and
we just ah sorry we've just lost all
humans and all stuff to help anyone with
anything so um
you can just send them a letter and then
they call you back i mean it took them
like 45 days to call me back after
sending the letter
but when they did i was just like i'm
just trying to give you money like i
don't get how that's a life hack
waiting so you would sooner have bad
internet for an extra 45 days
yeah then right so this is this is well
there's no other way to get hold like
because you try calling you just you
cannot it's just a brick wall so you're
like well how else can i get in touch
with them
i feel like you can write the letter no
don't be silly did you use a printer no
just
online thing you can send letters online
oh see you can you can write and send a
letter
online for about 50p really what's that
there's loads of services that do it so
you just you type up a letter or you
upload like a pdf or a word document
and post it for you oh wow that's
amazing that's
how's that not on your mouth on your
life like we've had today it's just so
embedded in like
what's the base of this we're
desperately trying to [ __ ]
pull every single we can out of this
weird service that calls you back when
someone answers the phone
when you've got this pure gold this
unobtanium level life hack sat there
right you know what you know why like
how often do you find yourself in the
scenario where like you need to print
something out it happens maybe like
once every six weeks yeah but when you
do it's like oh that's
all right yeah i'm going to put this in
this service and then your ink has run
out and then you have to get paper and
you're just
you've only gone you don't have any
stamps you don't have any envelopes you
have to go to pc world and get a huge
packard
you're like
and also the fact that i'm so blown away
by it means that i have no lateral
thinking
because obviously if moonpig.com exists
and you can send someone a [ __ ]
birthday card
you can definitely write a letter you
only know moon pig
exists because of moonpig.com like
where's that where's the virtual letter
service song oh man
it's it's part of my like paperless
ecosystem because i'm just so averse to
paper i'm so like
angrily like pissed off about paper that
i've just developed this like
work around for everything that involves
me not having to have a recommended
service then if someone needs to send a
paper
letter
it is uh cfh.mail.com
that sounds so bean yeah also
there's also lmail.com no use if anyone
anyone can google
this what we wanted was i'm not using it
so these are my
these are my favorites for alfred chris
these are my snippets so which don't
worry what are the two of them so
l-mail.com and cfh.mail
cfhdocmail.com wow okay so
we've worked out why this isn't working
johnny because all the companies that
have done it their branding
is atrocious one of one of those two
will break your imessage
so there's a really so there's a really
easy kind of business win there if
anyone's good at branding and marketing
just approach one of those companies and
be like guys branding's terrible
and you're offering such a good service
there we go
they're on the they're on the edge of it
aren't they with sending cards to people
like virtually sending cards and
presents and flowers and
if moon pig just pivoted and added that
service in
i reckon they'd they'd kill it right
i've got i've got three in a row that
are all
kind of the same thing so i'm on a i'm
on a cut at the moment
and dealing with hunger working out the
best way
to try and not break my diet and stuff
like that has
been something i've enjoyed playing
around with over the last three months
during lockdown so first thing i've got
this is taken from ben bergeron
which is if you get the hunger pangs
during the day
do a small amount of exercise so like 30
press-ups
30 squats um go for a light walk or a
light jog or something like that
because that actually switches off the
rest and digest
system and it changes the way that you
sense hunger
so if you do i promise you if you feel
hungry and you do 30 press ups
you don't feel that hungry anymore it
makes a marked impact on how hungry you
feel
so that means that you're less likely to
break your diet next thing
another ben bergeronism which is so
clever if you tend to cheat on your diet
on an
evening time or a night time perhaps
just before bed
clean your teeth immediately after
eating your
last meal of the day because you don't
want to then try and have food on top of
clean teeth it's just you feel like a
bit of a [ __ ] like
after you if you're like oh i want it to
enjoy this
but actually i've got minty fresh teeth
or whatever it might be
um and also going back to james clears
it's part
of the system of getting ready for bed
right like you don't usually eat after
you clean your teeth therefore clean
your teeth earlier
and the final hack i've got is just go
to bed earlier
on an evening time like if i cheat on my
diet it always happens at night
so if i make sure that i'm in bed with
teeth cleaned
maybe half an hour earlier that's it
i like i'm not going to get back up you
get out of bed
to go up and then make a bowl of cereal
to then get back into bed
so so that this is all increasing the
[ __ ] factor of any
of any like defaulting on it so it's the
fact that you have to then go out of
your way
and then you as you're doing it you've
got this big flashing light and you had
this
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you're like oh
hang on i can't do that
so i'm just going to go back to sleep
yeah yeah no that's it man
the press-ups went hungry thing i
couldn't believe it also i've
gotten into the routine of doing uh
press-ups just for a podcast
just to try and get a little bit more
awake because mine tend to be on an
evening time
and i guess that's similar to the it
puts you in like a like a peak state
almost yeah peak state fixed it so um
there's a similar strategy which one of
our clients used so ricky
great uh great suggestion on this one
was it's also called the five-pound
[ __ ] strategy i've got a video on it
which is that
he keeps a five pound or twenty pound
note in his back pocket
and if he's ever gonna buy food when
he's out and about so like
eating out or um you know doing
something that's off his targets
he has to pay for it in cash and
physically hand it over and then like
just to minimize the kind of contactless
payment
not thinking about the whole thing
process i like that it's the
increase in friction there was that
study done where they asked people
uh on the out the exit of a supermarket
how much
do you think your receipt was they took
their receipt off them and said how much
do you think your receipt was
and the difference in how people that
had paid cash people that paid card and
people that paid contactless
was insane
yeah i i couldn't tell you like if i pay
contactless just like because cash makes
it real doesn't it like having to count
the money out
makes it feel real whereas if you just
have to touch your phone on something
like oh
well that didn't happen do you do that
i'll deal with that later if it's a
self-service do you do that thing in
asda i try and do this where i'll pay
and then and then i'm trying to be out
of the door before it prints the receipt
like right that's it bag phone pocket
airpods transparency mode
yeah yeah spin i can't do self-service
it really
just oh it's so frustrating unexpected
item in bagging area and then you have
to go and get the little person to come
and help you you know
i'm just rather you know what i've
noticed about those right there's the
more
expensive the shop the the better
and the more trustworthy the
self-service system is you shop at
waitress the waitress
i don't i don't shop at waitress but i
have shopped at waitrose and if you do
use it at like a waitrose and m s the
like you can you can stick whatever you
want in the bagging area it doesn't
really notice
it's got like an ai machine learning
system yeah because the
bourgeoisie obviously aren't stealing a
pack of percy pigs
however the proletariat in the street
when they're in aldi you're little
like they're so true like they've
probably dropped the sensitivity to the
to be fair i've not set foot in a
supermarket in years so i don't even
know what they look like
um here's another thing i notice so in
asda in the
the self-service checkouts they have uh
an alert that says
um that's scanned please place it in the
bagging area
and that comes on so soon after scanning
something
that it's really irritating even with
noise cancelling on you can still hear
it a little bit
so what i think here's my hypothesis
about why they have it come on
so quickly is that you turn
that voice off when it registers the
weight
flat and static in the bagging area
so if you think that actually encourages
someone to scan stuff as quickly as
possible and place it in the bag
to turn the noise out what do we think
do you think that might be true
nice yeah i i think all these like
all these incentives that are created at
scale must be really really well thought
through
nothing i think nothing's done by
accident
nothing the placement of food in
supermarkets like where it is on the
shelves the ordering of things in shell
and shell fighting so like whole
science behind isn't it oh massively
yeah to get people to spend money and
play in these places
they've got different um different
rhythms
of music in mcdonald's at different
times of the day
so when they've got people with a high
turnover where they know that they need
extra seating and extra
capacity they have higher energy music
here to get people in and out of the
doors
it's the same reason why when you walk
into a supermarket they have like the
fresh fruit and veg and the flowers and
stuff at the front
how welcoming it is and the freezers
always tend to be over the far side and
all this sort of stuff
you're not supposed to walk it's around
the edges isn't it stay around the edge
for the healthy food and it's in the
aisles that's all
that's where they get you i mean you say
that but the bakery in as
the pastries yeah is on the edge yeah
yeah
yeah true yeah there are there are some
bakery based products to be hard to over
consume
just due to the volume if they've got a
buttery biscuit
yeah i just i really hope there's
somebody listening to this episode who's
not got any of the weird references
so far and just think we've all got
tourette's yeah there's tons of there's
tons of people that are getting exposed
to episodes for the first time
and to to all of you you need to go back
and watch
every episode all 185 episodes before
this one
so that you understand what it's like
joining grey's anatomy it's season 15.
so you can't do that you got to go back
you got to go back
right um we don't go back to our podcast
though we listened back to one of our
episodes recorded in like
2009 or something and
it was horrendous yeah man
it takes time it takes time to develop
to develop the skills right
anyway johnny what you got next up
this one might upset yusuf good good
thanks chris good
omnifocus doesn't upset me i
i want to love omnifocus okay because i
know completely
start using it so i i listened to a guy
so does everyone know what omnifocus is
it's a to-do list app so it's like
things or tik-tik or
to-do list or any of those things it's a
bit it's
it's got fewer um sort of fancy features
on it
but it's designed for gtd getting things
done
and if you've been if you've done what
chris said and has written to listen to
all the episodes leading up to this
you'd have heard david allen
talk about getting things done and why
that's such a complete
methodology david allen is on this
podcast this week
again no i haven't are we in the we're
in the timeline we're in the time
loop yes so this is going to go out
after after i've recorded without it
before i publish it
perfect perfect so so if you're
wondering what's getting things done
johnny
you'll find out later soon yeah um so
omnifocus
one of the things that i think is
something you'll probably
hear david talk about is how important a
review habit is
so a lot of people have a list lots of
people look at the lists
but then it's so something i've written
down here is like
one of the one of the best places to get
yourself to is feeling
okay with all the things you're not
doing
today or all the things you're not doing
right now so knowing that all of the
stuff in your world like all the
projects and the things you need to
remember and all the reminders
are in something that you will see again
at a regular time or at the right time
and omnifocus basically makes that makes
the review
feature the review habit very very easy
it almost almost automated so you when
you set a project or a task
you say to omnifocus like i want to
review this every three weeks
and it just throws it back into the list
that you look at
on a daily basis so what omnifocus is
really good at is
um it gives you like a menu of relevant
things
so you can defer things that you don't
even see them you delay things you don't
even see them so when you look at your
to-do list
you don't see like oh my god there's 70
things there you see well there's eight
things
i could do now so it's very good it kind
of has lots of layers
so the things you only the things you
see are things that are relevant right
now things that you can do right now
and that links into like the ability to
have
and this is quite a common feature
having like location based tags
or energy based tags so like i'm
in so i have a tag which is like in the
center of newcastle or at my parents
house that trigger
throw those things back into my
awareness when i'm at those places
and all i see on a daily basis are the
things that i could do then
tiny little things that nudge nudge
things forward some of those features
wipe the floor with things however some
of the
features that things has i'm going to
guess will wipe the floor with omnifocus
so if someone wants to go into the
rabbit
or the reddit uh wormhole that is the
uh gt method or the productivity slash
productivity subreddit um you will see
people getting
religiosity level angry about
whether or not omnifocus is a true gtd
app because it actually
allows you to defer at times and you
shouldn't have a time bet
all this stuff um currently i'm playing
around with things three
and i love it however
i am not using it to its full capacity
and some of the features you've just
said there with omnifocus
it's also great things doesn't have a
review function
so that's the minute thing this is why
there's no like best
productivity app because and the reason
people are so religious about them is
because they've got their own use case
or their own kind of
way that they would process themselves
they've lodged it to fix
the problem that it doesn't quite
actually fix which gives them a sense of
ownership over the way that it's now
being deployed
yeah exactly so something that which is
it i guess the
the hack that's relevant for anyone
regardless of app was i when i
moved over to omnifocus i bought a
course so i heard omnifocus being
described as
like learning to snowboard so when
you've i've never snowboarded
but you know apparently when you first
start a snowboard you're like falling
over and looking like you look stupid
can't work it out but then like after a
couple of weeks you're like
you know carving down the slopes and
everyone's really impressed anomaly
focus is
there's this big hurdle to get over with
setting it up so i bought a course that
guides you through that one of the
things the guy says in the course is
don't use fake due dates
or like times because your brain learns
to not trust them so he talks about like
you would only ever use a due date for a
to-do list thing
when there are actual major consequences
of it not being done at that time
and i like i said this to yourself a
while ago and i think everyone has the
feeling of like
yeah like that thing's g being due on my
calendar and now it's been over g for
three weeks it's like well it wasn't
actually due
then and all you're doing is d training
when you see a notification on a to-do
list app you just don't trust it anymore
it's just something else you've just
written you've used the due date as a
guideline for when you'd like to be to
get it done by
yeah it's just you saying i should
probably do this soon but it didn't have
to be done three weeks ago so there's no
point in using it like that's not what a
due date is for
what's the um what's the equivalent of
people snoozing
or um you know we were talking about
this a while ago when people like when
you're writing like a dissertation
and then you save the file as final and
then you're like oh final two
five or five final absolutely fine so i
see this
this is the most hilarious break in the
fourth wall stuff i've got partnership
with
bloomsbury and penguin random house and
bonnier books and all this sorts of
stuff
and i'll often get um so ryan holiday's
new book
uh the lives of the stoics which is
coming through is the first pdf i've
ever got ever in history which is named
the title of the thing that it is
every other pdf that i get which is sent
through with a
non-disclosure agreement saying you
can't fold this on and it's always
watermarked with my name in my email
so if i ever do decide to send it to
someone and they leak it i'm [ __ ]
clever
um but it's always um
the art of war um
fourth pass final um
like q qc ten out of ten so it's like
they've had the fourth pass through of
quality check it's ten out of ten undone
it's this or it'll be like um still to
have
cover all mad ma yusuf just left the
call
looks that way doesn't it can he rejoin
the call can we just continue now
without him
i think so here he's back oh you're mark
where'd you go
i don't know
it my life just went black trimming it
everything's going black
what's the course what's the course that
you did for omnifocus johnny i'll have
to get you the name of it cool
so the link to omnifocus and to the
course that johnny followed will be in
the show notes below
okay let's start uh let's start doing a
quick
quick fiery one um
final one so the foundation series
this is similar to the stu mcgill big
three
and it's by a guy called eric goodman
and it's a 12 minute training sequence
to improve your posture and improve
lower back pain and
the reason that i fall out of the habit
of doing it
is not that it doesn't improve my back
pain but just that it's hard and so
what i've done now is i've just used it
as a chance to listen to
um 24 minutes of an audiobook because
two times speed
hour in the morning especially when it's
sunny just out in the yard doing the
doing the program it's a free video on
science on youtube it's called the
foundation series
um founder or something 12 minutes very
unpleasant
but you feel like your glutes and your
hamstrings are just
on the rest of the day and your lower
back just goes ah
i'm not going to carry the load of all
this why is it better or different to
the big three stuff it's i think you can
do it in addition to the big three um
but it's more of a
it's more of like a a sequence um so you
can turn the big three into like a
pre-workout i have my big three done by
them
by the second so i know uh four minutes
and 40
seconds that i've completed my modified
curl ups i have 20 seconds to transition
myself into my side plank
side plank and then i've got a cat cow
like a one minute and 20 second cat cow
transition into the and then at 15
minutes and 40 seconds i'm done
so you're right you can turn anything
that you do sufficiently frequently
the about the ballet of the kitchen is
essentially kind of like a sequence
right like it's now it's a microwave now
it's the oven now let's do this thing
so is this a is this a injury prevention
thing or is this because do you guys do
this because of back problems
that's that's why i do it i i put up a
tweet the other day saying like what is
this
weird new wave of people that are doing
hours of
prehab in the absence of injury and how
i thought how is that become a new
training style
wherever we're just just everywhere you
see i i think i missed a memo between
now and
like 2015 and now that like has suddenly
made people
not actually trained for anything and
just do prehab
as their workout i haven't seen this man
i haven't thought we
i i think we're just subscribed to the
wrong the wrong people
like a lot of the pts on instagram stuff
are just doing like it's not pilates
it's not
specific injury rehab it's just like
stuff for the
point for the sake of it and people who
don't look like they lift that are
spending hours training every week
without a specific purpose or outcome
and i think if you're going to be doing
that stuff it has to be
with a goal in life the end goal yeah no
i couldn't agree more
um so my next one which i've been doing
for years and years and we've never
mentioned
is start with the weakest side
in a unilateral movement in the gym
so if you're going to do curls and
you're right-handed
start with your left hand or if you're
going to do
a single legged um like a romanian a
single-legged box squat or something
like that whatever it might be start
with the weakest
side first reason being that there will
be some sort of degradation to your cns
you're also going to even with a bicep
curl a seated bicep curl
you have to turn your midline on at
least a little bit so you have to
presume that if
you're fresher in abs in being able to
brace and being able to do all this
stuff
you will give your weaker side sometimes
minus sometimes perhaps even major
advantage which will help to bring that
imbalance
back up and i've always done it i've
always started with my left because my
left's so much weaker than my right
and um still not managed to balance that
imbalance out but so one thing you can
argue
is you start with the weak side and then
you match the reps with the strong side
rather than trying to
do more on the strong side until they
equilibrate
[Music]
so let's say you can do eight reps with
the left arm
ten reps with the right you just match
eight on the right as well
i'll see so you get slightly more muscle
muscly on one side for a bit
okay slightly more muscly but less less
muscly on the
side that's already more muscly until
eventually you just must leave
everything is well as mostly as possible
johnny what you got uh
watch a subtitled film
to help to combat with like two
screening or make it a more immersive
experience so i've had i get really
frustrated
i don't know why but when netflix upload
like for originally foreign films so
aren't they in english and they're
dubbed and it's really badly dubbed
so like the voice just doesn't fit the
situation like the the intonation
expression makes it like unwatchable
becker and i watched this film called
parasite the other week which is
korean i believe um subtitled in english
and i had really low expectations i was
like it's really frustrating it's like
i'm gonna have to read the entire thing
it's amazing how
ten minutes in you've almost forgotten
about the fact that it's subtitled
but you're completely engrossed in the
film because you can't even look away
from it
for five five minutes because you
completely lose track of what's
happening happening
so this only works this only works with
foreign films
because there's no reason to continue
watching exactly yeah
so i think there's a lot of good foreign
cinema a lot of good foreign series and
cinema a lot of them are dubbed which
i think makes everything worse because
you're actually less likely to pay
attention
but if you get the get like the version
that's foreign and watch it with the
subtitles often
they're pretty good i mean i like that
have you seen the platform
on netflix it's about i've heard i've
heard about it the concept is so cool
it's
people locked in kind it looks a little
bit like this prison
and there's two people per level and
like
50 stories and a huge big hole in the
middle so you can imagine that the
people live around the outside of a
square and in the middle of the square
there's this big hole
and this elevator goes up and down but
it was for i want to say french or
something like that
and um i just i went on started watching
it with the
british dubbing over dubs or whatever
it's called and
it was unwatchable so i was like i'm not
going to bother i'm not going to bother
doing it
um but if i watched it with something
it's such a shame
because it's fine it's pay please don't
kill me that's it
okay because like you think well you
know the act has been picked for the
role for a reason
right like it's not like you don't want
the actor acting and then someone else
not in the situation speaking without
the right more than just
because they have to do the work to get
the acoustics of the sound
to match where they are because like if
you're in
especially with that the platform film
it's a very unique acoustic environment
you know it's this very long uh brick
walled
thing and it's gonna have specific ways
that the sound bounces
it's so much less immersive like that
that's it it's the immersion that you've
got in it
if someone's on a beach but like the
audio sounds like someone in a
soundproof room
which it is which it is up against the
microphone with a pop filter like it
doesn't quite
but i would highly recommend parasite i
think it's on amazon price you do have
to pay for it
i don't think it's available for free
but honestly wow really paying
film i never thought i'd see so i saw
loads of adverts about it becca had
heard about it and it was like two weeks
ago and we're like should we watch this
like it might be [ __ ]
like decent chance at [ __ ] and then when
because it's subtitled like i resist
stuff like that
yeah but man completely changed my view
on it
um to just footnote that watching
a english or a native speaking
film with the subtitles on is one of my
least favorite things to do
yeah because i can't not read the
subtitles which means i just don't watch
the film
this is my problem i'm reliant on
subtitles now like it doesn't matter
what language it's in
sound wise because i'm just so subtitle
i think i just process
information better in text than even
for entertainment yeah i just rely on
subtitles
hold on so if there's a visit in english
it's the english series
english audio yeah i'll always prefer
subtitles and
you're not watching the you're not
watching it then no i'm just i could be
reading a book i suppose
but re reading like karaoke style book
that's blowing my mind yeah me too i
hate it
there's nothing i like there's nothing
that i dislike yeah man
so that means you get the benefit that i
got from watching the korean film from
everything
yes because you can look away i think
that's the thing isn't it like
you you don't have to pay attention but
i i think my problem when i'm watching
something is not like i want to look
away or
check another screen i think if that's
the case then you're watching something
that's too boring
what is your reason for using subtitles
when you can already understand the
words then
i just my comprehension percentage is
better with
again this is my point about
entertainment like there's no quiz after
finishing this episode of breaking bad
yeah but
you still want to be able to under like
why would you watch something if you
don't understand it i don't why you can
you know
who's i'm just i'm just not very
[ __ ] smart only piece of the puzzle
that's not fitting for me is that
i feel like of everybody i know you have
the best audio comprehension because
you're on like two and a half times
speed yeah
on audio still it's still better i think
like just having an extra
way to that immersive reading thing
that's quite popular at the moment would
be something that i could see you do oh
it's lovely yeah i
i should maybe train the habit of not
using subtitles to become better at
understanding playing around have you
got have you got any more
skills yeah so uh i've actually just
used it now with the parasite and the
platform
which is to have a list of
things to watch or things to read and
just have it in a queue because
there's nothing worse than if you get to
the end of a season or whatever and
you're like oh well
what do i watch now you don't want to
just pick the thing that netflix
suggests for you
so if you've got something that's been
highly recommended like the last thing i
watched on johnny's recommendation
was the gentleman fantastic oh wow oh
yeah that new guy richie
excellent excellent phenomenal film
would never have watched it without
having that life hack in place or i
would have forgotten about it how are
you
sorry you should watch this and you're
like oh okay and then two months later
when it comes time to re to watch it
you've forgotten
so i just have an evernote list with a
queue based on
how how much i trust the person who's
recommended it
and um how much i think i would like the
show and if i would have access to it i
imagine you move up or down the list
depending on
like when you watch something if it's
good you're like um
johnny's taking the piss a bit here
we'll move oh yeah all of johnny's
metrics are now down right so what's at
the top of your list currently
so let's have a look
while he's doing that yeah succession
if no one's if you haven't seen
succession that's tremendous
succession gangs of london
um so the top ones are also johnny's
recommendations
there's defending jacob that's brilliant
and
decoding bill's brain so that's not me i
don't think
that's george what was that jacob
defending jacob what's that it's on
apple tv it's about
like a a kid who gets accused of murder
wow yeah there's so much good stuff out
at the moment i guess
a lot of studios have realized that
because people have got more time at
home that they really need to capitalize
on it
um yeah we've got tons of stuff watch
watch parasite on amazon prime watch a
gentleman succession gangs of london
defending jacob
this is this is ramping up this is a big
fat one um
um so this is my favorite hack that i've
developed i've already mentioned it on
isolation hacks but i'll put it in
properly here
for listening to podcasts that have
mid-roll ads if you're on iphone
you can simply say to your iphone hey
siri skip forward by
60 seconds or hey siri skip forward by
90 seconds
for instance if you're listening to ben
shapiro i know that his
by doing this that his agreement deal
with his advertisers is a minimum of a
60-second mid-roll ad
um but he always says we'll get to that
in a second but first and as soon as he
goes but first if i say
hey siri skip forward by 90 seconds i
land just as he comes back in
and that's your insider knowledge isn't
it that's your but you're you can see
them
you'll get there you'll get their event
like true geordie it'll be
everyone every advertiser that you
listen to every podcaster will be 60
seconds 90 seconds or 120
and most mid-rolls aren't going to be
that um but especially with someone like
rogan
you know that you can skip forward
probably by six or seven minutes
to catch the start of his guest intro um
i'm speaking to brett weinstein today
and we're talking about blah blah blah
so philosophically how is that
misaligned how is that different to
having spotter free
oh can you use spotifree
to get past mid-roll ads in a podcast
that's that's not what i'm asking though
like
i'm saying how is it philosophically
different
to have something that mutes the
60-second spotify adverts compared to
because you have to you have to sit for
60 seconds in silence
well that's fine it's music so in a
second i thought that you
paid or you use an app to allow you to
not have to sit and wait in silence for
someone
but you're happy to sit and wait in
silence whilst music's
in between i just use spotify as like
background music so if there's 60
seconds of silence
the fact that you've chosen to use it in
that way doesn't defend the
uh discontinuity between those two so as
long as we don't fall out about it so a
podcast
which which like is only being supported
because of the adverts and only
able to run because of the sponsors
but we're like they don't make any more
money by me listening to them i'm not
buying it whether i listen to what i
know that's like saying
using chrome with an ad blocker like the
only reason why
google what google's predominant ad
revenues from ads so if you're blocking
the ads but using chrome and using
google
well spotify don't make any more money
by someone skipping or less money by
skipping the adverts
or muting them we think well not yet
not until rogan comes through but i mean
the main my main problem with spotify is
that you don't have access to spotify
premium and you get around this
because you use spotify on your macbook
a lot rather than on mobile
but the difference in how much people
use it on
ios or whatever versus on mac os is
going to be
huge the vast vast vast majority of
people use it on the phone which means
that you can't choose
songs you can everything's got to be on
shuffle
which is like disgusting yeah i don't
know if i've even got it on my phone
actually
well there you go just maybe the problem
like i'd i would bet
that a whole host of people the vast
majority of people who have spotify
probably don't have the app on their
laptop
interesting so then it's yeah then it
becomes
a no-brainer to just buy it i think so
but
i i think you make an interesting point
my
my
justification for it is i can listen to
a 55 minute ben shapiro podcast
in 40 minutes at one time speed because
that's how many adverts are in there
so would would you also you know there's
certain apps like castro which cuts out
the silence between
like dead silence and podcasts but the
problem is it then like means people
have no pauses between what they say and
it's really hard to comprehend what
they're saying
no because i want to listen i want to
consume the content as it's created i
trust ben
to be able to give me his delivery in a
way which maximizes what i'm supposed to
consume
so actually ben well there's no he is
like that thing where all the silence
has been removed but sam harris's most
recent um
episode on can we pull back from the
brink which is amazing and everyone
that's listening should go and check it
out
um he's 90 silence yeah he has a lot of
scientists he's just
he talks in guided meditations but
the the silences in there are done
for not only effect but also to allow
you to consider what he's doing it's a
two-way
conversation between you as the listener
and him as the producer
you're supposed to allow your thoughts
to fill those gaps
and the same i had daniel
schmacktenberger on a couple of weeks
ago
and bless you there is one section
in that where he's silent for 20 seconds
20 seconds of silence and i could have
cut it but i was like actually i mean
he's left this
in for a reason he's stayed silent
because he's contemplating something
are you here to purely index the
information that daniel gives you
if so i can just get a transcript
written and give you the transcript
or are you here to actually be an active
participant
in the way that this conversation
unfolds
that's the check that your airpods
haven't run out of battery the number of
people that were like dude i had to
like check and see if you guys had
stopped and i could see it was still
playing and i thought that there was a
problem with the file
and no it was just 20 seconds later he
responded remember when star wars did
that
no there was a one of the more recent
star wars films there's an explosion
in space because obviously it's in space
and there's no sound in space
it it went silent they had loads of
apparent i mean it's just i'm
remembering this so don't criticize me
if it's wrong but apparently
loads of people complained because they
thought they'd have to hear like a loss
of hearing
in the cinema actually just accurate
physics actually
just yeah but you can test if you've
lost your hearing if you're sat in the
cinema what an idiot like there's
loads of people going like
yeah um johnny are we all still friends
after the ad thing
um so this is something that i have to
like i made fun of this for a while um
it's something that i found through
googling um
there's a podcast that tim ferriss did a
long time ago where he talks about
productivity he talks about like
how just focus on one thing for two or
three hours in the morning that sort of
stuff
and there's a the actual quote or the
written transcript from the podcast is
in the front of
something called um is he gone
i'm still here i'm just going for a wii
u okay why is he tearing the video off
because i don't want to say i don't my
wii to be on youtube
oh hang on so you're now in the bathroom
yeah
oh not just i'm not having a wee at my
desk right yeah but you could have just
left your desk oh but you don't want to
miss what johnny's about to say
let's see yeah can you mute your mind
for the very for the
benefit of the listeners please um so
it's called
the productivity planner so something
that i have been
doing more with like
it's based off the uh
obviously the the six minute diary or
the so the same people who produce the
five-minute journal
make the productivity planner it
basically just forces you
to when you're thinking when you're
scheduling your day you can only write
down five things you're going to do
the most important thing then two
secondary then two additional
and you also have five things in a week
and that sort of thing um
very simple paper-bait i'm quite
enjoying like paper-based
uh so i use omnifocus as digital but
everything else is paper-based so like
journaling habit tracking everything
else is is physical
um you can probably see it there sort of
on the
side of that sofa so in the morning i'll
use the journals one by one or use like
the
the things that i'm using one might want
to move them from one one side to the
other and then i'm
done it feels like a done yeah exactly
i've got
i've got that one i've got that one over
there okay i've also got the michael
hyatt
full focus planner oh nice which which
is
according to jordan airs even better and
i have to say upon comparing the two it
definitely seems like the full focus
planner might be an interesting switch
for you
um once because you want to get about 90
days out of that right
of the productivity plan yeah yeah so
it's just i thought i thought the full
focus planner was more like
just general journaling i thought it was
more fun
is it all work-based stuff is it yeah
exactly and it also allows you to
revisit
where you are getting to with um weekly
monthly
goals um it's really clever but i've got
next time that we see each other which
actually might not be before your 90
days is up on that based on the
moment um i'll be i'll be able to show
you it but jordan jordan's had both
and he's now on this full focus planner
thing and highly highly recommend it
but the the productivity planner yeah so
the only reason i
i looked so i've seen it before and i
was like you know that's it that looks a
bit stupid but it's made by the
the five minute journal people it's
based around
tim ferriss's like productivity
philosophy so it's very simple
and it for i think sitting down and
thinking
if i'm only going to do five things
today starting with some a big project
and then
all the way down little things it's
actually pretty hard to do that
it's the intentionality man yeah it
forces prioritization
and then you realize like when you still
sometimes do only four or five you're
like
i completely overestimate i have no idea
what i'm able to do yeah
absolutely man i i really really agree
and a lot of people that are listening
if you were like i was
a little while ago you'll start your day
upon having to do some work
but not actually know what you're going
to do is that right time to sit down and
do
work and it's just this big amorphous
blob that is
work time but it's like if you have a
set list this is it's going to be this
then it's going to be this and it's
going to be this
like you never have to guess what you're
doing next yusef why have you put kermit
the frog
behind you on your he's turned his mic
he's turned his mic off and he's tried
to do it for comedic effect
he's he's back again can you can you
just
tell me when he goes i cannot i cannot
believe
that you that you've tried to do the
only thing that i can say that's
the um redeeming feature of that is it's
not the man with the huge penis
that you put on before we started
recording because if you'd hit the wrong
button there
dean would have had an absolute
nightmare trying to pull you out of
the drawer so we'd have had to the worst
thing that you can ever say to yusuf is
we're going to have to scrap the
audience again yeah
[Laughter]
so i i saw someone using this effect the
other day
it cracks me up because now all i can
see is chris's description of
it looks like a five-year-old is colored
in your ears
yeah so is that a is that a life hack
don't use
the fudged desk effect
on skype just watch out that kermit
isn't behind you sometimes
he creeps up have you have you got any
more
yusuf oh let's see
i have uh so we've done the foundation
series
this one is not actually one that i use
because i have a second monitor
but if i had an ipad the new version or
the current version of mac os
has a feature called sidecar which means
that you can
use your ipad as an external monitor
side cart
side car car cycle so
um and that can be wireless or it can be
wired so you can literally just set up
your ipad on a stand and you've got two
displays having two displays
is a life changer for getting things
done
reference document on one side task on
the other or like
even having your omnifocus or your
things or your
to-do list on one side and then
and so there's there's two quotes both
from sam evans
so chris will get upset but you said
might listen so one of them is there's a
direct correlation between
how unproductive someone is and how many
tabs they have open yeah in their
browser and here's a it's not a quote
but it's an idea of
him saying like why if you're only ever
able to do one thing at a time
would you need two monitors active at
one time
so that that is that's a good question
so what i do it for is if i'm like
let's say i'm doing a web page design
and i've got the original page on one
and then the the creation page on the
other or the preview or
um text like reference and
and production you can also use so if
you use tick tick it has a built-in
pomodoro timer that you can use to fill
up an entire screen that just gives you
the task
that you're doing so it's like a big
real
real pomodoro that i thought i was going
to ask whether or not you you do that
pretty cool so huge counter timer yeah
big countdown timer the name of the task
in the middle of the screen and that's
it
and then you're like right [ __ ] it yeah
and then
come at the frog on the other screen is
there something a ptsd
is there something specific about it
being a second display
rather than it being let's say just a
32-inch display
because you could get the total you
could get the total amount of screen
space from a very large display someone
could just plug the tv in
is there something specific to do with
the fact that it's two distinct discrete
displays
yeah so so one one way to say is that
like if you have an external display
it's something that you may be it's it's
officially a secondary display so you're
not
using it as your primary focus but there
are
there is a display that you can get i
think it's like 1200 quid which is a big
curved monitor so it curves towards you
and that way you would actually just put
your
macbook or whatever you know vertical
stand over on the side and not look at
it
and just have the entire display in
front of you you can do the same with
vertical displays too if you're a coder
and you've got like
multiple lines of code above and below
then you can use better touch tool
and keyboard shortcuts to send windows
to
either side of that i bet that would
take if you had like a big whatever
couple of feet wide display i bet better
touch tool would have a little bit of a
time getting it together but once you
had it fully
set up that would be pretty command
shift left or command shift right
nice to me i uh i still haven't moved on
a better touch tool i need to it's only
very recent for me i have an initial
resistance curve with all of these
things
i want to make sure that yousef doesn't
get arrested or like something doesn't
happen
something bad doesn't happen and then
once i like it's still fine
i usually adopt that's the same with
alfred that's a scoby probation
so there's a probation period attached
to the architecture of the scoby problem
which is inbuilt to the time space
manifold
and once he's managed to get through
that which is usually around about six
months or so
with no scoby problems occurring that's
when you can fully implement it
with safety margin and you're like okay
i think it's safe it's because
discovery and turnover of apps and like
the improvement of the pro of the
process is so
violent it is high noise high noise low
signal
but i think like the the sediment left
over those are the things
it's the buttery bit it's the biscuit
the basically the buttercream
biscuit base um okay my next one
we talked a little while ago about flume
which is a
mac app which gives you full
functionality
for um instagram fantastic allows you to
upload photos if you get the pro version
which is only about one or two pounds i
think
you can have unlimited accounts to
switch between so especially if you're a
social media marketer or something like
that
and you want to be able to monitor
multiple accounts fantastic service for
that
however the one thing that it doesn't
support
is temporary images on
your inbox so that that is every story
that you reply to
or that someone replies to of yours
which for the vast majority of people is
how they're driving dms in their inbox
most of the messages that you get are
just a response to something that you've
put up
um but it doesn't support it however
instagram.com
direct slash inbox has the full
functionality of your entire instagram
inbox
on a browser and supports stories
story messages allows you to see pretty
much everything there's only a couple of
times
where someone sent something i've not
been able to get i think it's like if
it's a disappearing message which is not
replayable once and it's sent by of
people that's not a friend and whatever
um but essentially
that now and because you have if you
just use instagram.com you can just
click the little
um envelope icon you don't need to go to
that url but it is in the show notes
below
um if you go there it's just as single
focused as using flume and getting rid
of all of the different tabs
because you don't see anything else
there's no other bits popping up
so you can go on reply to all of your
messages and then
leave so this is a new function of
instagram and what you can do
if you still want it in the kind of
packaging of a mac app
is there's many apps now that allow you
to create electron based
um basically a browser tab but
or the mobile version of a browser tab
as a separate mac app
so you basically put in the url and it
generates an app for you
with the instagram icon that's like
adding um
a web page to your home screen on ios
right and then it kind of becomes an app
yeah it's exactly that man and what's
that called
there's loads of tools that you can that
do it um
some are better than others and they
keep out competing each other so i don't
want to give the name of one and then
it's like it doesn't turn out
this is the same as the productivity
tool stuff man like until someone comes
up with
the like omnifocus 5 that ends up taking
80 of the market or things 10 or
whatever you know like that ends up
winning everything
and to go to just quickly loop back to
the productivity app
comment i asked david allen like whether
someone's made the app that gtd deserves
and he basically said no
the long story is like there isn't an
app out there which does all of the
different things that it needs to do
yet um needs to be interfaced with your
brain
basically that's what you said that's
exactly what you said oh did you you
listened to it didn't you
i've had the the inside scoop yeah did
you enjoy that yes
i already i think some of the stuff that
he said like
while disappointing i did i didn't
expect him to say
like because he just uses a uses lotus
notes right and he uses a
pile of paper and a pen like it's not
well when you've been doing this
from for the last 30 years you're not
going to be
up to date with something which isn't
lindy you're going to have
something that you've that you developed
the workflow for in like
the 90s yeah then you've grandfathered
it in well so i think like his point of
like it's more about the
it's about the way you use the tool the
approach yeah so it's like do you have a
capture process
are you processing those things do you
review them then it doesn't really
matter what you use it's just like what
makes most sense for me
it's why it's weird that there's so many
like note editors when it's like
at the end of the day like you just want
something to put text into and
those bits of text which it's lists and
documents
files and folders isn't it like it's not
it's just that and then like loads of
people make that really complicated yeah
i have to say i
really really love um notes for
icl ios notes or imac notes or whatever
that's my that's my go-to for stuff
that's not serious and not long form
i'm just looking here all icloud notes 1
330. but they're nested
they're nested in the right in the right
subfolders and they're
you can have tags and stuff like that
but um
it's just so good like and it is because
if you use apple devices they have a
disproportionate advantage over
everything else because it's always
going to be quicker it's always going to
be better integrated it's always going
to be blah blah
limited space as well flotato
is one of the market leaders for that
for the uh
how how does it spell like potato but fl
flo tictato potato fl
there's also native fire which looks a
bit bean i've not used that one it's on
github which means it's going to be very
beautiful you think it looks bean
when i can't
period not completed to be honest if
you're using native fight if using
anything off github usually it doesn't
even have it's it's not even compiled
like the developer's just giving you the
code and you have to then compile it
yourself
so you've got to then open it in
terminal and do a home brew and
turn it inside that way like you're in
your bathroom with a big like
vat of beads what's it that you and
becca do is it gausto or blue apron or
whatever oh yeah
gusto whatever yeah are you liking that
to github
yeah it's the tech version it's all of
the things
that you need to make your evening
dinner but it's your job to do it
however pay us over price
yeah whereas potato is just like here's
a chicken curry that's
in a pack pie in the are you in the
microwave like the
github's like a recipe book it's like
look here's all the things you would
need
to buy and how to do the things with
those things to make it into this thing
gusto is a step ahead of that gusto's
like the app store okay
cool yeah again let's not fall out about
it
have we got have we got time have you
got one each for a super super
quick fire round as long as it's really
quick because i do need a wii that's
fine
just take the thing with you yousef did
yeah i was desperate i'm not going to
take my
laptop to the toilet i just just morally
i just have a problem with it fine
johnny have you got it
oh god um
can you feel the pressure shall i do
mine while johnny's looking
he's looking uncomfortable yep
it's not really a hack it's just
something that again from sam evans like
crystal loves sound muffins like he's
always had enough of it sometimes he
just rings me and says
have you listened to this video from sam
evans i'm like yeah chris it's brilliant
um but something that he talks about
which is quite useful
for just general personal development
when you're sort of observing yourself
is determining your
maximum and minimum tolerance for
something that you're trying to change
so everybody has an amount of money in
the bank account where they like
start to look on online shopping a lot
and you know they're like oh i'm flush i
spend a bit money
but everyone else has the panic number
and everyone has the weight
on the scales like maybe not you two
because you absolutely the whole time
but most normal people
have a panic number and they're like ah
i can be a bit more
like you know i don't i don't need to
worry about so like observing those
and observing the behaviors that happen
when you start to reach those triggers
it's one of the easiest ways to just
like
nudge your reference range down
something he talks about is the thing
you consistently achieve
or the thing that consistently happens
in your life is your minimum acceptable
standard
so you'll very rarely get above your
maximum acceptable weight you'll very
rarely go below your minimum acceptable
amount of money in your bank account so
like if you
change those that's one of the easiest
ways to influence your behavior
i really like that how do you change
them what's his advice i think just
just he his his advice was just simply
it
like a lot of people have those and
operate in that way but aren't
necessarily aware of it so there might
be
the first yeah like there might be a a
level of tidiness you allow your
like desk or desktop or kitchen or
bedroom to be
before you like all right i need a big
tidy so like trying to notice what that
is and think up that's coming i'm gonna
do something before it
ahead of time just becoming aware of it
it's a very like watery vague fluffy
thing
it's not easy to instantiate but it's an
interesting uh reflection al
and bottom had a thing the other day
where he cited some old philosopher
talking about the fact that humans go
through these cycles
and he actually had if you can imagine a
snake snaking its way from top to bottom
in a mid-range like the interquartile
range of some graph
and that's hegel hegel yeah when you
vacillate between
political spec our sides of the
political spectrum or
or the the sam ovens video is called
face off with the devil where you yeah
you have these like top and bottom
points where it's
sine or cosine isn't it yeah nice but
not not tan okay not what have you got
it's a contactless charger
but this one stands up so i think the
problem with
normal contactless charges the flat ones
is that because the
charge magnetic bit it has to be aligned
properly with it
you end up having to fiddle around a bit
i'm in with you i'm i
i am so we have this problem well i have
one
oh yes it was what i decided to buy when
i first got an induction charger for my
phone
i thought i always got another one but
i have to be incredibly precise about
how
far up down left and right it is and if
it's slightly off whereas if you use an
upright stand i've been thinking this
for ages
man you nailed it you nailed it so it's
fixing the point
fixing a point where you know well if
that is there then the rest of it must
be
too many degrees of freedom on a flat
induction charger
i had a few instances where i'd like put
my phone on it at night
and i'd wake up and it hadn't charged
it's just dead
it took two instances of that for me to
be like right now
suck it off the induction charging all
together so if you've got um
if you've got an apple watch as well
then there are some that have a stand
and a little
watch thing yeah i've already little
apple devices on one
place which is quite nice man i think
that obviously if you sleep with your
phone outside your room
then which you should you know anyone
that's listening to this away from
outside of the room like digital sunset
is increased that's i'm
upright induction charger i am all over
that what have you gone for with the
charger
uh this is a bean 1.1
that's so close so close i can lever it
so my final one is if you're listening
to an audiobook
which you need to focus on turn the
volume up
so much of the time when you're
listening to something you'll just
listen at a comfortable level i'm not
saying make your ears bleed
but if you have something which is
louder
a little bit louder i tend to take more
notice
i tend to not be able to have my
thoughts be as distracted
you have to presume that your ability to
think of something else is a function of
how much you're not able to think of the
thing that you're listening to
and if the thing that you're listening
to is taking up more of your
consciousness more of your senses
to turn it up a bit and if you're
worried about it being too loud
you can go into apple health and it
tells you
whether you're hit whether your
headphones have been turned up too loud
or not
have you done the thing on siri where
you go hey siri turn the volume up to 80
percent
and then it gives you the warning where
it says that's very loud
are you sure have you had that i've not
had that now
that's because you've got a pair of
airpod pros and you've never had to have
it above 65 percent
yeah but yeah louder audiobooks or um
podcasts for comprehension definitely
seems to be something so it's like you
get that you get the 10-pound headphones
and then at some point have to pay for
hear it like to see a consultant to talk
about your hearing
or you just buy these expensive nice
ones
yeah you're right uh man this list from
today is absolutely
massive everything that we have gone
through will be linked in the show notes
below or in the description on youtube i
will find some discount codes
some affiliate links or whatever i can
get hold of to try and make you hack
your life
for less guys people want to check out
your stuff what you got going on at the
moment anything you want to direct them
to
just go to propanefitness.com
all the fun stuff happens there like you
might think this podcast is good
check out that stuff check out that page
yeah but that is that is predominantly
for
personal trainers or anyone looking to
take things online business wise or
propertyfitness.com forward slash
calculator
for the macros for the secret magic
macro in fact you can even just get
the macros on propanefitness.com
don't even have to go to the calculator
you probably have to use the calculator
but yeah yeah you can use the
connector yeah uh also check out proper
and fitness instagram you see if you're
putting up some cool stuff at the moment
man i know you've got
a million things premiered and scheduled
for the next few months
i'm on twitter you're on twitter use us
on twitter i'm not on twitter yeah i was
gonna say you've never been on twitter
ridiculous
bloody very stupid yes thank you
gentlemen everything that we've gone
through including propane fitnesses
uh appropriate links for you to check
out their stuff will be in the show
notes below if you haven't already got
your copy
of the ultimate life hacks list 200 ways
to upgrade your existence that will be
linked below as well
gentlemen until next time oh do you know
what it is next time is going to be
episode 200.
20. doing a q a 100 fan q a so if you've
got some questions that you want me
johnny and yusif to answer
episode 200. we will be reading them out
live on air
thank you thank you oh thank you
thank you
okay goodbye then bye then
bye dan bye then bye then